Speaker 1: All right.
Let's now move to Trump's next weekend appearance.
He appeared last night on the Mark Levin probe.
I'm on Fox News this you have to see the topic
of Richard Nixon came up.
The disgraced former American president and
Trump delivered a two minute word salad that
is almost beyond linguistic comprehension.
This may be Trump's worst interview of the
year.
It's only April, but folks, it'll get worse.
But this may be Trump's worst interview of
the year so far.
Let's listen to Trump's completely confused
word salad.
When the topic of Richard Nixon came up.
Speaker 2: He was a very tough guy.
He was I guess some people would say this
about me, too.
He was his own worst enemy.
I mean, I can say that a little bit about
myself, much less so than people think, I
will say.
But he was sort of a paranoid guy and it's
okay.
You know, you keep your guard up.
I don't say that badly.
Speaker 1: This is just an electric amount
of energy from Trump.
As you can see.
You can also tell Trump's a real history buff.
Speaker 2: His views on Henry Kissinger were
very interesting.
I won't tell you exactly.
I get along pretty well with Kissinger, but
I tell you, his views on Henry Kissinger were
not so hot.
And he was a tough guy.
And he he they went over to tell him that
you have to get out.
His biggest regret, according to his daughters
and I think according to him pretty much was
that he didn't fight.
They went over there one evening, Barry Goldwater
headed up the delegation and they had some
senators and some congressmen, and they went
over to tell him he's got to get out.
And he left the following day or the following
morning.
And his biggest regret was that he didn't
fight because it wasn't really like him.
And I find that very interesting.
And his daughter, when I got impeached twice
by.
Speaker 1: By the way, it's not that Nixon
didn't fight Trump the history above Nixon
fought and fought and fought until courts
made him turn over the tapes that showed he
was complicit, complicit in the scandal, And
leaders of his own party approached him and
said, We will impeach you if you don't resign.
Nixon did fight, but the Republican Party
had the strength of will or the moral clarity.
I mean, I don't want to overstate it, to say,
hey, you got to go.
It wasn't made up of lunatics like Jim Jordan
and Marjorie Taylor GREENE at the time.
But Nixon did fight.
Speaker 2: Yeah, really crooked, disgusting
politicians.
You know, they just happened to have a majority.
And they the Democrats do stick together and
they on a perfect phone call.
Think of it on a perfect phone call.
This was a call that I remember Tim Scott,
the senator from South Carolina, read this.
He was the first one to say he read the call
because I had it.
It was taped.
The call was taped.
He said they didn't say anything while he
was saying, like, what did he do wrong?
Was a perfect it was a congratulatory call.
But I'll never forget when that happened.
We had such great support.
Nixon had no support.
You know, he just didn't have support.
Very, very tough with people.
Speaker 1: Just an endless circular word.
Salad.
Speaker 2: I get along with people.
I mean, I have great Jim Jordan and all these
congressmen are great.
They're really incredible people.
Speaker 1: This is so Trump There's more,
but it will stop it.
They're just electric energy from Trump, as
you can tell.
Then, as I told you earlier, the topic of
dictators came up and I kind of like this
question from Mark Levine to a degree where
he points out, You seem to really get along
well with genocidal maniacs.
What's up with that?
And I know Levin's not even really trying
to be tough, but it is a funny moment.
Take a look at this and look at keep an eye
on Trump's reaction.
Speaker 6: I ask a question about that.
You have really fascinating letters in here
from Putin, from G, from on in North Korea.
And I can go on and on.
And what I notice there's a common thread.
You had a personal relationship with every
one of these leaders, whether they're genocidal
maniacs, whether they're elected like Abe
of Japan, who was a close friend of yours
and was assassinated.
I want to get into some of this.
Speaker 2: What would you say your foreign
policy is, please?
I think people keep projecting on to your
foreign policy.
Speaker 1: Well, Trump has no idea what his
foreign policy is.
Basically, he just lusts for authoritarian
power and that's why he admires these tyrants.
Speaker 2: I'll see what it is that they think.
Speaker 1: They want people to.
Speaker 2: Think your foreign policy is.
What would you say it is?
So I think more than anything else that it
was a very personal relationship.
And, you know, it was sort of a weird situation.
The tougher they were, the better I got along
with him.
And that's probably a good thing because it
was a tough one.
They had the two big, powerful countries,
the ones that can do destruction.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is so much simpler.
This is so much simpler.
For whatever reason you want to say it is.
And you could say it's because of Trump's
relationship with his father.
You could psychoanalyze, you could you could
come up with 20 different reasons as to why
Trump is enamored with these authoritarian
strongmen.
And sometimes they are genocidal dictators.
He's enamored with them.
Trump's not impressed with diplomats like
Angela merkel or Justin Trudeau.
Emmanuel Macron.
He's he's not it's not impressive.
And in fact, Trump's relationships with our
historical Western allies were significantly
damaged while he was president, and the U.S.
was increasingly not even a part of many important
discussions with our historical allies.
While Trump was president, Trump was enamored
with the dictators and the authoritarians,
and that's fundamentally what it is.
And we could psychoanalyze Baguio until October
as long as the day is.
We could see we could speculate about that.
But that's the reality.
One more weird moment from this interview
with Mark Levine on Fox News.
Trump says that China Rape.
America.
Speaker 2: And I got it back in the form of
taxes, tariffs and other things.
And with hundreds of billions left over and
no other president got $0.10.
And yet I got along with President Xi incredibly
well.
But I was stopping the rampage.
It was the rape of America.
That's what it was.
It was the.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the rape.
China raped America is Trump's latest thing.
These interviews, Mark, my words, are going
to get more and more insane as Trump's legal
troubles worsen, potentially with more arrests
and indictments.
And if Ron DeSantis does get in the race,
which I don't know that he's going to, we'll
talk about it.
If the Sanders doesn't get in the race, it
will also be hugely triggering to Trump